la mort de la gazette de l'île aux
enfants d'en manquer la gazzetta la
gazette de l'île aux infos il ne s'est
rien passé dans l'îlot z'enfants
d'amendé la gazette
bonjour monsieur lys noir un bon je
m'envoie casimir que les ce journal que
je n'ai pas l'honneur de connaître ça
c'est la gazette de l'île aux enfants un
nouveau journal dont casimir et le
directeur
c'est à dire moi fantastique étonnant
les fantastiques je vous ai ton premier
client ton premier lecteur
enfin une personne de ma qualité se doit
de se mettre au courant de l'actualité
d'ailleurs regard j'étais en train de
lire les journaux du matin
combien coûte t journal c'est gratuit
fémina stick courageux mais fantastique
tout en remercie les émirs excusez moi
je continue ma tournée je t'en prie
voyons cela il ne s'est rien passé dans
l'île aux enfants c'est tout fantastique
décevant mais foot astique qu'amendé la
gazette de l'île aux enfants
françois tu veux mon journal mais bien
sûr casimir c'est une très bonne idée de
faire un journal de l'île aux enfants
comme ça nous serons au courant de tout
ce qui se passe dans l'îlot en forêt il
s'en passe des choses dans l'île aux
offres
je sais c'est une excellente idée c'est
gratuit c'est vrai gratuit c'est
formidable ça casimir
voyons un peu il ne s'est rien passé
dans l'île aux enfants c'est tout ouais
alors morpho casimir dans un journal il
doit y avoir des informations des
rubriques puis ce n'est pas possible
qu'il ne se soit rien passé
casimir si tu veux que tout le monde lit
son journal il faut que toi le premier
du saut au courant de tout ce qui se
passe et ensuite bien telle approche
électeurs et je crois qu il te faudrait
aussi ce serait très bien des petites
annonces bon oui j'aurais plutôt pensé
le contraire moi enfin puisque tu le dis
bon je continue ma distribution d'amendé
lac
cette eau l'île aux enfants dans la
bonté la cas du lait c'est le fameux
journal dont tu m'as parlé oui julie
c'est la gazette de l'île aux enfants
et qu'est ce que tu as tu as mal à la
gorge non mais françois on m'a dit que
pour bien vendre un journal il fallait
faire des annonces petit mais non il a
dû te dire qu'il te fallait faire des
petites annonces et oui bah c'est
exactement ce que je viens de dire
pas du tout je vais expliquer ce que
sont les petites annonces
imagine par exemple que tu es perdu ton
chien tu as bien vite l' envie de le
retrouver
alors tu écris au journal en lui donnant
la taille la couleur de ton chien
l'endroit où s'est perdue l'adresse où
tu veux qu'on te ramène et le journal le
lendemain publient tous ces
renseignements les lecteurs peuvent
aider à trouver ton chien c'est
formidable non bah oui mais c'est tout à
fait inutile mais pourquoi mais parce
que je n'ai pas de chien
enfin casimir c'est un exemple une
supposition les petites annonces peuvent
que servir aussi à trouver du travail ou
à acheter une collection table à vendre
et d'accents cinq ans ava j'avais
compris je ne suis pas complètement
idiot mais je n'ai jamais pensé que tu
étais battre quasi casimir
qu'est-ce que j'ai une idée pour ton
journal il te faut une équipe de
reporters ah bon monsieur du stop trop
soir j'espérais mais je les services
vous avez besoin d aide
non c'est casimir qui a besoin de lui
pour son journal mais mon journal et
très bien faye il dit la vérité il ne se
passe rien dans l'île aux enfants
casimir julie a parfaitement raison pour
que tout le monde liste au journal nous
allons devenir porteur et nous allons
aller dans toute l'île et te rapporter
des nouvelles sensationnelles
nous allons sur l'actualité l'a précédée
in heaven non ça va être fantastique
partout tout de suite oui j'avais deux à
quatre mois je suis ce chemin
et bien moi je vais par la case ih
miraton nous ici à tout à l'heure
le directeur ils veulent des nouvelles
sensationnelles événements ouais eh ben
ils vont voir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
vous êtes là ma chère amie alors vous
allez trouver une information
intéressante non et vous au mot non plus
je pourrai dire que j'ai mal aux pieds
mais son intérêt sera personnes
je vais brûler mes amis rien aucune
information nous non plus casimir avait
raison regarde toi tout et ballons qui
sont crevés ça non mais je n'ai pas
marqué mais met cap une versa et mes
bonbons fourrés ils ont tous disparu
offert abomination que vous disent les
journaux mais précieux journaux
quelqu'un a renversé de la peinture
dessus semir sensationnel il se passe
des choses terribles
comment table casimir chrtr tous les
ballons de françois moal sensationnel
normand de la gazette casimir mange tous
les bobos fourré de juillet qu'est-ce
que casimir anvers de la peinture sur
les journaux de monsieur du ch'nord
comment as-tu rosé mais croit pas c'est
de votre faute vous m'avez dit qu'un bon
journaliste devait créer l'événement
je crois que nous avons pris une bonne
heure ça c'est bien vrai